ah  there you go  Mr Speaker I'd like to address the house  about how children feel about masks  remember I was going to say it's going  to use an expression we have to keep our  country gay but but it's not I mean for  some reason it's just not great anymore  do you frequently go to Hardee's is that  a common place you go okay that's pretty  funny David no it's not a joke when you  talk about the machines I just want to  clarify you mean electronic voting  machines and those because people write  to me and they say I'm worried Mike  pillow is gonna come after my espresso  machine my lathe my all these other type  I'm sure I'm sure they do David now  you're just being sarcastic and the  little left-wing humor  that could be your headline Mike Lindell  wants to get rid of the machine